when Arkham Asylum came out having Joker
be the main villain was a complete
no-brainer and having him voiced by mark
hamil only further cemented that
decision as a solid of course why
wouldn't you and it made sense that he'd
be a major player in the sequel Arkham
City because why the hell would Joker
just fit one game out if he was in the
vicinity of everything going on of
course Arkham City SWAT did have some
problems like for example that big
reveal at the end were the main villain
behind everything he wasn't Hugo Strange
but instead was a guy you would already
successfully beaten up like four hours
ago kind of took the impact out of it
then to tie it all off Joker slides in
at the end and reveals he's been
manipulating Batman the whole game so he
can put himself back on top after
everyone else is either exploded or died
of a horrible disease then it kind of
doesn't go so well for him it was a full
decision to kill off Batman's main
villain and it was probably the best
ending for all four of these games I'd
also like to note that with the sudden
influx of character death it was
apparent that the Arkham games were now
in their own universe and that thing
that I liked about Arkham Asylum is now
null and void then Arkham origins comes
along and sells us with the fact that
Batman vs a whole mess of various DC
assassins and bad guys only to have that
fizzle out about halfway through when
the main villain pulls his mask off and
says hey everyone you're not allowed to
have a Batman story without me
apparently
so Joker is the villain of the first
game is basically the villain of the
second game then shows up and feels the
spotlight as the villain in the third
game and then in the fourth game he's
the main villain even after he died I
think this just demonstrates the weak
writing that a lot of that man's story
suffer from they tend always suddenly
forget that he has such a huge rogues
gallery if someone once had the gall to
say Batman has all the best villains why
can't we get any of that League games
like everyone else is just a B Lister
that's only worthy of being Batman
grocery list of extra [ __ ] in
between chasing the Joker Arkham City
even had that weird plot with Hass using
stolen human faces to look like Bruce
Wayne
we can't make a whole story out of that
just a minor scuffle in an office where
no one gets killed
okay then Paul Dini left the series and
none of the new writers cared enough to
try something new and different it's a
brand new universe with no baggage from
the comics or continuity to dance around
they had a perfect clean slate and a ton
of possibilities for new avenues to
explore in a Gotham without the Joker
then they loosely adapted a comic story
and shove Joker into it even when it
made no sense and all it did would serve
a contrived function in the plot
Joker being Batman Tyler Durden is an
interesting concept at least but its
place in the story is to effectively
handicap Batman when faced with villains
he would mop the floor with on any other
day not to mention his entire existence
as an imaginary friend for Bruce seems
to be just because Batman gets a dose of
Scarecrow's fear toxin and instead of
putting him into a nightmarish drug trip
Wonderland like it always does he makes
him manifest the Joker is an alternate
personality if there is any way to have
all the tension in a scene disappear
instantly it would be to have Mark
Hamill's Joker voice coming out of
Batman's now look at me amazing so [ __ ]
consistency he's a fear toxin in dude
fever dream fine but the B plot of the
game decides to offer an additional
reason for him being there and that's
because Batman is slowly turning into
the Joker was a lot Joker why because
[ __ ] consistency Joker was dying in
Arkham City because he pumped himself
full of the Titan formula into turned
him into this I'm no doctor but I can
tell you whatever chemical is used to
make a person into that are not exactly
going to be the healthiest things to
have in your blood so Joker is a mangled
mess after it's a super voids because
his ribs are literally hanging out of
him and he decides to donate a ton of
his poisoned blood to both Batman and
Gotham's hospitals the Titan formula was
what made him in Batman so sickly not
just that it was Joker's blood in fact
Joker's blood should be fine on its own
aside from his looks he's just a human
being the chemicals that the factory
changed his skin pigment and hair color
we fell in
nah like he was bitten by a radioactive
clown
so Arkham Knight the game informs us
that for no reason at all
Joker's blood is now making a few random
people turn into him wait what why let's
think about that for a second
Joker's the entire personality and
complexion can be recreated by a blocked
blood transfusion gee that kind of
undermines the whole one bad day thing
if it's all based on genetics or weight
said undermines the entire appeal of the
Joker as a character if he can be just
duplicated that easily does that mean
that Joker's mental problems aren't real
and are just a side effect of the
chemical okay if the toxic blood gives
you mental problems why is it so
specific as to make you an angry
anarchist who wants to murder and/or
sleep with that man why did the poison
in the tighten formula not kill these
people as opposed to the hundreds that
it did kill before it killed him Joker
sent his infected blood out to all the
hospitals in the state I know we tracked
it all down we missed some if that man
drank the Cure that is literally made
from the Fountain of Youth
would that not just mean he's fine why
doesn't that work anymore at the end of
the game when Batman caught us his fears
of becoming the Joker does that somehow
magically cure him of turning white and
green even if he beats the mental
aspects of this stupid disease when he
still has to deal with the physical
aspect of you know what never mind
this story decides to make so many
unjustifiable leaps in logic that asking
real questions about it is only wasting
time however I am an expert at wasting
time gee I need to figure out where they
could possibly be producing factory size
quantities of this dangerous chemical oh
look this spy plane and scanner
equipment told me it's the local
chemical factory world's greatest
detective everyone The Joker being here
is an over complicated way to disguise
the fact that both the main villains are
as interesting as drywall and have about
as much motivation to destroy the city
and kill Batman - scarecrow went from
being his
usually middling OneNote self to being
an unusual OneNote self instead of just
being a weird henchman who gets off on
the concept of fear he suddenly decides
he wants to be the god king of the world
and what the country with his beard at
and he wants to tear down the image of
that man in ruin his life
and he wants to destroy Gotham and he
wants to be the ruler of Gotham after he
destroys it I guess all this because his
face got mangled by Killer Croc one time
I mean if it was a simple revenge plot
you think he'd be more angry at croc
than say everyone else like Hawk is in
the city he's right over there you have
the men and resources to go murder him
super hard and payback for your face now
it's Batman thought okay you're dairy if
I only had a brain wait what the hell
did scarecrow have the gain from
pretending to refrigerator Barbara
Gordon how the hell did he know the fear
toxin would make it look like she killed
herself anyway how the hell does he know
what specifically Batman would be
hallucinating from the fear toxin
what if Bruce's nightmare was that him
and Barbara just had sex on a rooftop
instead this is a really bad idea to
imply that the Justice League exists in
this universe because even if Batman
loses Superman or the flash will
probably end up taking down scarecrow
anyway so his lording over the ruins of
Gotham won't last long I give it two
days max which reminds me let's take a
moment to really run through scarecrows
plan shall we he'll produce enough fear
gas in the eighth chemicals plant to
destroy the city which is now totally
vacant save for his own soldiers and
whichever random criminals decided to
stick around really the only people who
don't deserve getting gas or the cops
one police station worth of people a
world domination plan does not make
money
so after this inevitably fails miserably
the game starts telling you of his evil
dastardly plan to use a device to
blanket the city in fear gasps but this
was just like a back-up plan
what if Batman hadn't destroyed the
eighth chemicals build
would they just not even use the
cloudburst I guess I appreciate that
Johnny C over here is being proactive in
thinking ahead but the narrative seems
to play it off like this was his plan
all along
so was he just hoping the 8th chemical
thing would fall through and wasted all
that time setting that up for nothing
how about this scarecrow attempts to
blow the a of chemicals building and
have Batman come and stop him but while
he's doing this across town in the
district that's already controlled by
Arkham Knights militia activate the
cloudburst and Batman can't do [ __ ] to
stop it even better protect that island
with all the tanks you have so that the
Batmobile would get annihilated if it
said even one wheel on the bridge
oh I'm sorry being effective isn't the
same as being spooky and savoring
revenge or whatever
we both know fear theatrics Batman
scarecrow in Arkham Knight the person
not the game are both ultimately undone
by their obsession with stupid theatrics
they have all these resources at the
ready and they continue waiting to use
any of them until after Batman just got
done crashing the last round of new
tricks up their sleeve if they just
threw everything at him at once you
wouldn't have any time to adapt and the
game would be over in an hour who
[ __ ] cares if Gotham sees Batman fail
or if his crusade is ruined everyone's
been evacuated and the only people who
would see it up close or criminals who
are minutes away from biting their own
tongues out because you dropped super
LSD on them Jesus who wrote this oh-ho
stay off the streets the floor is lava
actually wait this reminds me of
something
then again the arc tonight is the second
title character and feels like a
complete afterthought I swear his entire
character was written around getting the
word Arkham in the title jason is a
dumbass who does nothing the whole game
except to talk about how he'll
eventually do things but then just kind
of not get around to it that's right if
you have eyeballs you've been spoiled on
the fact that Jason Todd is the Arkham
Leto I mean the chair at night so
according this game's universe Jason was
kidnapped by the Joker and taken to an
old abandoned way
of Arkham Asylum to be tortured for
months before being faked kills for some
reason Batman's having flashbacks to
events he wasn't even there for a really
dynamic glow just like that and that new
kid is hated oh you think so
this isn't Batman man this scene implies
that he had assumed Jason was dead by
this point already and got a new Robin
which means he's imagining a scenario
where he thought Jason was dead but knew
he wasn't by virtue of having a
flashback at all and he still can't
figure out who the arkham knight is the
arkham knight so then were treated to a
death scene for jason in which he shot
in a video that Batman watches and then
never follows up on at a flock
convenience you mean to tell me that
Batman never went looking for Jason and
just took the video as evidence enough
that he was a goner well at the very
least he could have went to go get the
body and give the poor kid a proper
burial
the real slap in the face about this is
that if Jason died in a room of Arkham
Asylum
why on earth would Batman not have gone
looking for him in the comics Jason is
beaten and killed in Africa and he still
goes to find him now they say it
happened down the street from his house
and he didn't even bother you [ __ ]
instead of dying right off Jason was
tortured for months and mentally
programmed to hate Batman I guess okay
Jason Todd hoodie hey instead of used
this for something and say turn Jason
into a joker sidekick to hurt Batman
feelings mr. J shoots him in the
shadowed region and then does a classic
Joker sign-off did did Joker just miss
and assume this was a kill shot before
leaving to go do other stuff did he
actually plan to fake Jason's death how
did Jason get out of this situation and
go scour the earth for a four billion
dollar anti Batman army
where did he get that money has he ever
been to college
yeah there's no route this I think what
pisses me off most about Arkham
night a person is that he's such a
half-assed adaptation of his awesome
comic counterpart they butchered his
character so monumentally the appeal of
red hood is that he represents the flaws
in Batman's philosophy and is one of the
few characters in the DC Universe who
can make a legitimate argument against
Batman the fact that Batman never killed
the Joker or anyone for that matter it's
kind of shocking when you find out his
adopted son with tortured and beaten to
death to prove a point Jason Todd has
every right to be angry that the Joker
is still walking the streets and killing
people on a daily basis because it shows
less of a moral integrity in Batman and
more of just a weakness that anyone
could exploit his fear of crossing the
line goes from being Noble and heroes to
more of a character flaw but not as too
interesting Jason should just be mad at
him
I'm not sure cage hey look that's a
great opportunity to kill Batman or late
never mind he's a skeleton the Scarecrow
and give up for no reason okay this is
even better situation Batman's got a
bullet in his abdomen he's on the ground
helpless he's surrounded by 500 armed
men just empty that pistol and who was
Jon spray his face all over the back of
his cowl or just not do it okay what
about now when you have two guns pointed
out I forget in a world where pretty
much everyone thinks Batman killed the
Joker
Jason character doesn't have much of a
leg to stand on and it's made even worse
when he tries to explain his anger and
only comes off it sounded like an idiot
took so many changes to kill him it's
your fault Joker got to me every good
argument he could make is gone every
interesting angle on his morality is
gone he is totally fine with killing
thousands of people
and a-lying himself with a faceless
terrorist stop Trump okay Jimmy
they made him a whiny teen brat who
turns evil where the Corki robot suit
hates his old mentor for no reason and
hangs out with a hooded figure with a
deformed face oh my god he's Anakin
Skywalker in episode 3 this really does
have the writing of a Star Wars prequels
oK we've established that the villains
make no sense under complete idiots but
let's talk about the dumbest one of the
bunch it's Batman he's the dumbest Dylan
for whatever reason this game forces him
to make every wrong decision imaginable
it's not done in a way that shows
Batman's humanity and vulnerability he's
just acting like an [ __ ] I think all
things considered Tim Drake probably
hates his guts after everything that
happened one of the strange things that
man seems to be doing all night is
telling everyone how dire the situation
is and how this will be the last time
they meet after Yelp's with their side
missions this is the end this is the
last time we meet don't talk like that
it means this is the end Selina it means
we can I will see you again right no one
will but I can't help but ask why the
hell does Batman think tonight's the
night when it all goes up in flames
I mean Arkham Knight and scarecrow are
kind of bad at their job and he doesn't
exactly seem to be showing a ton of
symptoms of turning into bat Joker other
than the eye color in fact a slight turn
of events and the entire ending could be
avoided and Batman could continue his
life unabated with everything going just
fine This Is It this is the worst ending
to a game since Mass Effect 3 I know
that's a bold statement but I'll stick
to it after Batman succeeds in taking
down pretty much everything in his past
as for his custom the thrilling climax
to World of Tanks Batman addition is
that scarecrow is by himself in a room
with a gun and two hostages um okay this
is Batman we're talking about I'm not
one of those guys who overhyped Batman
to death and said he can beat anybody
ever but this is one of the times where
I feel like he could probably handle it
storage Depot
go there alone or your friends will die
dick scarecrow has Batman go to this
shady ass warehouse and leave behind his
utility belt under threat of executing
Jim and Tim Batman doesn't need his
utility belt to get out of rough
situations they just help the suit is
filled to birth with lock picks and
secret components and pockets
not to mention probably a dozen types of
tracking devices to let Alfred Nightwing
and Robin know where he is so forget all
that the utility belt makes the man
without it he is nothing Batman has a
long weird spirit journey in the back of
the truck and by the time he gets to the
ruins of Arkham Asylum all that's left
to oppose him is scarecrow holding a gun
in the middle of this hazy transition
Batman had to consciously let scarecrow
strapped him to a gurney while he's
holding a gun in one hand and a glove of
syringes in the other someone please for
the love of God explain it to me oh the
humanity if only Batman was some kind of
expert escape artist and could figure
out a dozen ways to break his mighty
bombs if only he had some kind of
special move to swipe scarecrows gun
away and take him down in one swift
motion oh god he's so helpless umm I do
that begs the coin a phrase
what are you dead are you [ __ ] or
something who the hell do you think I am
I'm the goddamn Batman the reason the
ending of Mass Effect 3 pisses people
off or one of the many reasons anyway is
that Shepard suddenly forgets how to
talk his way through a situation if
there's one thing he's been an absolute
expert at all the way to this point it's
convincing people to do things for him
or agree with his perception and right
when you would need that most in the
darkest hour of the whole series he just
forgets how to do all that because he's
tired and injured so instead of
convinced the Reapers to just leave and
go fly into the Sun or something he acts
like a huge [ __ ] and goes along with
whatever the star child forget
I think you see what I'm getting at here
this ending makes Batman just flat-out
give up and let a b-list villain destroy
him
you know why he gives up not for any
good reason it's because Rocksteady was
tired of making Batman games this is how
the Batman died you don't have that as
the opening line of the game if you plan
to make a dozen sequel Batman himself
acts incredibly out of character and
borderline suicidal because he has as
little regard for his future now as the
developers do they let their feelings
about the series lead into the story
this is only a Batman losses scenario
because they wanted to make it clear
that they're done and want to go work on
other things The Dark Knight movie
series did something similar but they
didn't have all the characters become
dangerously incompetent to create this
situation they just built a wall around
Batman main character powers and let it
fade out more naturally I'm not saying
you can't tell a story where Batman
effectively ends they've done that a few
times actually I'm saying you can't do
it in such an insulting way and I'm not
saying this game completely sidestep any
interesting themes or character growth
but when the circumstances surrounding
those are so pants on head stupid it's
hard to take them seriously
Batman succumbs to his weird mind trip
with the Joker for a bit and soon
figures out a way to overpower his
personal boogeyman cool fine whatever
where the hell or any of his friends
Nightwing make your way to my location
now Nightwing and Catwoman are both in
the city right now doing their own thing
remember in Arkham City when Bruce gets
trapped under a pile of debris while the
city crumbles outside and Catwoman had a
change of heart and went back to go save
him instead of bail it tied up the two
plots nicely and gave her a greater
purpose in the story than just being
filler even if you didn't free her yet
in this game before this Nightwing is
still out there doing nothing except
searching for suspicious-looking white
vans and if this takes place after you
beat both of their side missions then
two people who care about Batman a lot
his lover and his son both hear him
saying cryptic [ __ ] about how he
we could die tonight neither of them are
concerned enough to follow up on that I
won't let you down thank you I
appreciate it
so instead of the logical option we get
Jason Todd swooping in to save the day a
whole five minutes too late why the [ __ ]
did he even bother coming back here him
and Batman never really made amends he
just beat him up and said sorry I'm
sorry that was enough for Jason to pull
a complete 180 and go save him man only
his problems were always solved as
easily Kelly could just go up to
two-face and apologize for mangling both
halves of his head and Harvey would
return to a life of politics well Batman
is outed and his life is over I guess
because everyone gave up so after 19
hours of grinding on the side mission he
mysteriously stumbles into his house it
explodes on live television and then a
bat person presumably using fear toxin
shows up in the epilogue to gobble up
some criminals congratulations everybody
this is what this entire award-winning
series was building up to was it all
worth it I also took this clip off of
YouTube instead of getting it myself
because with their trophy
god what a mess I'm surprised more
people aren't tearing their hair out
with anger and how this games turned out
yeah the DLC stuff was pretty cool yeah
the graphics are great yeah the voice
acting is stellar but everything else is
either underwhelming overwhelming or
just stupid what the hell happened in
the development process that led to all
these poor choices
Rocksteady didn't close out the series
in a satisfying way they just rushed it
into an Arkham grave so they could go
develop hell I don't know maybe they're
making a Justice League game or
something now I think I felt so
compelled to review this game because
some of its flaws are so massive yet
avoidable there is so much wasted
potential here and that's worse than
just making a game as bad it's a game
that's mediocre at best even though it
could have been amazing
if the Batmobile was used sparingly if
the script had like eight more drafts to
iron out all the nonsense if Harley
Quinn wore that's the whole game the
gameplay felt more balanced it's a side
mission Sims feels like busywork at the
boss fights in suck at the Riddler
segment we're actually fun in challenge
seppius if the mask fit on Batman's face
in a way that didn't look horribly tight
and uncomfortable then it would have
been a fantastic game and there is
nothing worse than stumbling right
before the finish line on the positive
side there's no way this will be last
Batman game of its kind
I'm sure if a different developer
doesn't pick it up Roxy will start a new
series that borrows design elements from
this one and I'm really excited to see
where the telltale series goes after its
first season I just wish this one had
turned out differently because I love
the Arkham game there's some of my
absolute favorite and I feel like it's a
series that deserve better than to end
up like this keep in mind if this is
your favorite game ever
for whatever reason that's totally fine
my opinion is not fact and you weren't
wrong if you like things about this game
let's just skip all the no man this game
is perfect you're just a hater bro
comment I can't afford to lose any more
brain cells we're down to double digits
now what that being said the Arkham
origins actually that bad guys think
about it that one has some neat stuff in
it despite being kind of cheaply made
[ __ ] I'm gonna go [ __ ] play that one
again Oh guess that's the end of the
Arkham Knight